good evening ladies and gentlemen and
welcome to this press conference
following the informal meeting of the EU
heads of state and government now
without further ado I first invite the
President of the European Council burns
was active on thank you good evening
might you lead us match to a 50 outcome
of the European elections and to discuss
what this results mean for the you as
well as for nominating the new heads of
the European institutions first and
foremost we are very happy about the
turnout which was the highest in 25
years this proves that the use of strong
pan-european democracy which citizens
cobalt whoever will lead the European
institutions they will have a genuine
mandate from the people at the same time
we will have a slightly more complex
Parliament requiring at least three
parties to form a majority this also
makes the European Parliament more
representative it will reflect a much
greater diversity of youth and national
sensitivities this is a truly democratic
outcome and I am personally very happy
about it for me
and is also based on the leaders
discussion these results are a good omen
for the euro and for future Europeans
the vast majority voted for a more
effective stronger and United you while
rejecting those who want a weak Europe
this is a powerful sign Europe is the
winner in these elections in fact such
people have become more pro-european
some major skeptic parties have
abandoned the
anti-eu slogans and prevented themselves
as EU reformers this is a positive
development I have no doubt that one of
the reasons why people on the continent
voted for a true European majority is
also brexit European see what breaks it
means in the practice they also draw
conclusions drugs it has been a vaccine
against anti yo propaganda and fakers
now on appointments and the lead
candidates today's discussion confirmed
the agreement reached by the leaders in
February last year that the European
Council will exercise its role when
electing the Commission president
meaning in accordance with the treaties
that there can be no automaticity at the
same time no one can be excluded being a
lead candidate if not a disqualification
on the contrary it may increase the
chances the treaty is clear the European
Council should propose and the European
Parliament should elect therefore the
future president of the Commission must
have the support of both a qualified
majority in the European Council and the
majority of the members of the European
Parliament
we also discussed balances that if they
need to reflect the diversity of the
Union when it comes to geography the
size of countries gender as well as
political affiliation this will be our
genuine aspiration but as I already said
in Sibiu in the real world a perfect
balance may be difficult to obtain
I will now engage in consultations with
the European Parliament as foreseen by
the treaty to kick-start this process I
have already offered to meet the
European Parliament's conference of
Presidents as soon as they are ready in
parallel I will also continue my
consultations with members of the
European Council both on the future
president of the Commission and on the
future President of the European Council
and the European Central Bank as well as
the High Representative I can promise
that I will be as open and transparent
as possible I hope that on that basis we
can provide clarity on all these posts
or red engine but I also made clear in
Sibiu this depends not only on my
goodwill but also on a goodwill of
everyone involved before taking
questions I would just like to say that
we did not discuss names tonight just
the process so please don't ask me about
names
thank you Thank You president I now open
the floor for questions I think we start
with the gentleman in the third row okay
two questions the first one you said
that the perfect balance might be
difficult but would you prioritize this
time around maybe the gender balance
unsecured at least two women for the top
post and the second question are you
concerned that by including the ECB
presidency in the in the packets you
might be politics are you might
politicize supports that otherwise will
be I mean the independence would be the
most important attribution of this post
it's not only my aspiration to have a
real gender balance among the leaders
new readers of our institutions and
there was a very visible majority around
the table determined like me understand
right the balance means at least to do
we mean if it is possible we will see
but this is at least my plan and my
offer my personal ambition and as I
mentioned I felt a very strong support
maybe not from everyone but almost
everyone also in in this aspect when it
comes to ECB it was also clear I my
message was he also very clear that if
he is not for the party competition if
he be extremely independent
politically independent institution and
all my interlocutors are aware of this
fact but we have our treaty obligations
here I mean it's our role to decide on
on this we need for this formal
recommendation from our finance
ministers but for them it's also
important to know what is really
possible among the leaders because at
the end of the day after also the
hearing and the European Parliament the
leaders will decide on this it means
that I think that they are experienced
enough to recognize the difference
between our nomination for ECB and the
other political nominations I am I think
here quite safe and comfortable all of
them
about this difference thank you I'm
trying to ensure some gender balance yes
please Thank You Catherine Fiore you
reporter sorry to bring up the B word
but Theresa May was at this summit and I
was wondering if you had a chance to
discuss with other leaders the situation
that is developing in the UK was there
any discussion of the leadership process
in the UK and you've always been the
person who's been quite supportive of
the extension of all the candidates
there's only there's only one who is
appears to be opposed to accepting as
possible No Deal brexit and that's Marie
Stewart and he was put forward this idea
of citizens assembly to discuss the
details of where the UK wants to go but
that would take an awful lot of time
would you welcome a further extension to
allow the UK to make a sensible exit
thank you I'm sure that we will find a
better opportunity to discuss brexit
maybe after our European European
Council meeting in June because frankly
speaking Bridget was not on our agenda
and no one even try to discuss brexit
today and for us the presence of Teresa
made something pretty natural
she still British Prime Minister and the
UK is still the member of the European
Union and I have no doubts of also after
our discussion today and my short
meeting Christie resume that
and the UK will be as constructive one
comes to our European procedures as
before and as dissenters before I have
no no doubt Thank You Christian good
evening I tried to understand you met
the President of the European Parliament
earlier on and he gave you the
decoration which had been adopted by the
principle groups saying that the
procedure is closed only to the Schmitz
and candidate and the lead candidates
but you said today that nothing is
automatic so you're giving us the idea
that the door is still open so is there
a possible just problem between the two
institutions there and because there are
people talking about external candidates
such as mr. bunny and others who just
want to stick to the lead candidate so
what do you say I think that it was
clear from the very beginning also in
the Parliament that for the European
Council the treaties application are
more important and political ideas and
inventions and this is why we repeated
just two hours ago our position which
was declared during our European Council
meeting in February last year
there's no automaticity and I think
there's no it's not a problem at all for
our partners in the European Parliament
to accept this fact at the same time my
intention and also it was absolutely
clear to our discussion today that all
of the leaders want to have a best
possible relations with the European
Parliament during the hour
Ephesians and we have to respect as I
mentioned in my in my introduction today
we want to respect the European
Parliament of also they the opinions and
for sure
beaten candidate and procedure this is
something what is not it's not a
disqualification to to be a spittin can
do that I am absolutely sure that I will
find because I declare not only I I
should declare this but difficult for my
belief that that you will find the best
possible way to negotiate with the
Parliament because it is our common
interest to find a much political
majority not only among the leaders in
the council but also in the parliament
and no one is no one is interested in in
the in the institutional conflict
especially between the council and and
Parliament and I think that today's
discussion and our conclusions that the
best guarantees that that we will do
everything to avoid any risk of tough
conflicts among the institutions
thank you
and the last question goes to Jennifer
thank you I try own brexit again if I
may because in this room two months ago
you said you asked the UK please don't
waste this time and we're now in the
middle of a Tory leadership contest
talking about renegotiating the
agreements so do you think there is good
use of the time being made in the UK or
are you worried about a no deal brexit I
think my appeal is still valid I have
nothing to add to do my worth nothing
because I have no new information
interview yeah
oh here what is the state of things in
in London today nothing promising and I
should say but okay my and our role
today is to to to wait for some new
solutions and I want to be as dedicated
as possible and I'm not in the mood to
to to find a new formulation on you I
appeal to my British colleagues thank
you very much this concludes the first
conference